I'm taking yo garlic pretty much like a
black heart is something that's your
you're born with like if you're born
black you're born with a black card it's
a lot to do with your knowledge of
blackness and a lot to do it just you
just really being black like it once you
brought like a black along with yeah we
were T like you acquire your black card
you're born with it you don't
necessarily learn finding new yorks with
one yes and with this conversation I am
so nervous that I'm going to lose it you
have a black I went to a white school
[Music]
I'm stuck between B and C because I
believe it was Joe Lewis and because I
think Hamid Ali was fighting him but I
don't know if he was heavyweight
when you play oh no I'm going to go with
B because I don't think he would fight
Muhammad Ali if you would buy in his
weight category I mean it would be
because it sounds like something my dad
might have talked about I remember my
mom giving me a book about Jack Johnson
when I was a kid and that's that's one
thing I remember now if you told me I
was wrong and I just made that whoa
right okay so this is kind of hard for
me I'm not ignorant
I know I know these authors and I know
that book but it feels like all those
first three could be yeah like it's very
same genre of like style of writing I
feel like even I feel like it really
could have been
see look at how many Morrison how it
would be yeah look at Giza go what I was
gonna say was one thing they kept
preaching at Howard now like I cannot
say the wrong word good here you know
the answer I do another thing we've been
preached are all those women black the
first one I'm just not sure I'm taking
your car away they don't just have to go
off of what sounds right I go with me
[Music]
and that wasn't that like one of her
like first ridings I'm like a major
newspaper that was my second choice
can we is there an option for oh yeah
for sure it's just like like sorry you
know would be be thank oh yes no that's
a quick slap I feel like you see but I
feel like bat talk is less disrespectful
because that's you being like this is
what I think you know I'm saying you
talk about when you do see that mean
it's you can on something you walked
away and said how might I make some
noise about Islamic though oh I will
inflame the doors because I know have it
I'm stuff between sandy because if you
slam my mom's car door slam any house
door like she will lose it she'll stop
you doing come March down the hall yell
at you if you call her by her first name
like don't you dare call her yeah you
will get backed off if you like back off
or if you roll your eyes if I call my
mother by her government that will be my
last words yeah I don't know what
happens past
rights all right we all get it yeah the
majority and this is my life from
Detroit if I get this wrong they're
gonna disown me it was definitely yeah
okay that was the abolishment of slavery
or the end of slavery okay
well technically slavery didn't end when
the Emancipation Proclamation was ready
[Music]
I'm educated and fixed I think it was a
really big deal when I happened yeah I
bet I know the story I wrote an essay on
it Hallie had that speech Hallie
Alex reach where like he was hella
emotional when she got an award I mean
everybody does that like 2003 I'm not
confident at all I'm too or I'm just
like I apologize
just fold you're good I am that's the
problem would what letter was
and how Hey yes no I remember how did
Daniel one was it Gone with the Wind
gone with the wind and then had to go
and sit back down in the color table
after she accepted her award I think I
know this one
thank you dr. Carr I'm just like I want
to say one but then I feel like that's
not it and then I don't have to say C or
D but uh micarta t Wilson started like
History Month you seriously y'all
thought y'all guys on are like oh that's
BB welcome dr. Carr Carta G Woodson this
was stressed restful I couldn't come out
of this hot jacket for continuity but
I'm so wetting but I appreciate the fact
that this company has a history element
yeah I'm surprised how many random black
history guys I remember and you know
it's like I did the culture was I can't
speak for these others you guys but I
thought but we're learning this I'm sure
for them to like they didn't learn all
these facts from school
after this learn your history very nice
do you know where you come from so you
can know where you're going oh so if you
liked this video and you want to play
this game just click on the link below
[Music]
you